if we're moving from cat to dog which
are similar things so we go away from
cat and towards dog let me go further go
beyond in that direction yes so the
first result is dogs which is kind of a
nonsense result the second is pitbull so
that's like the dog use of dogs right
the least cat like dog that feels rods
yeah yeah well if you go the other way
what the most cat like cat the most
undock like let's find out it's gonna be
kitten right it's gonna be cats feline
kitten it's gonna not really giving us
anything much to work with I thought I
would talk a little bit about word
embeddings word to vac and just wording
betting's in general the way I was
introduced to word embeddings or their
their sort of context that I'm most
familiar with them in is like how do you
represent a word to a neural network
well it's a set of characters isn't it I
mean it needed me more than the set of
characters that make it up right so you
can do that but you remember the thing
we were talking about before in language
models you have a problem of how far
back you can look I would much rather be
able to look back 50 words than 50
characters and like if you if you're
training a character based model a lot
of the capacity of your network is going
to be used up just learning what
characters count as valid words right
what combinations of characters are
words and so if you're trying to learn
something more complicated than that
you're spending a lot of your time
training just like what words are and a
lot of your network capacity is being
used for that as well but this isn't a
hard problem we know what the words are
right you can give the thing a
dictionary and then you're kind of it
gives it it gives it a jump start the
point is a neuron networks they view
things as like a vector of real numbers
or a vector of floats which is like some
of the real numbers and so if you think
about something like an image
representing an image in this way is
like fairly straightforward you just
take all of the pixels and put them in a
long row and if they're black then in 0
and if they're white then it's 1 and you
just have greyscale in between for
example it's like fairly straightforward
and so then you end up with a vector
that represents that image it's a
reasonably good representation it sort
of reflects some elements of the
structure of what you're actually
talking about so
like if you take if you take the same
the same image and make it a little bit
brighter for example that is just making
that vector a bit longer right or a
point in that configuration space that's
a bit further from the origin you can
make it darker by moving you're close to
the origin by reducing the length of
that vector if you take an image and you
apply a small amount of you know noise
to it that represents just like jiggling
that vector around slightly in that
configuration space so you've got you've
got a sense in which two vectors that
are close to each other are actually
kind of similar images and that some of
the sort of directions in the vector
space are actually meaningful in terms
of something that would make sense
famous and the same is true with numbers
and whatever else and this is very
useful when you're training because it
allows you to say if your neural network
is trying to predict a number and the
value you're looking for is ten and it
gives you nine you can say no but that's
close and if it gave you seven thousand
you can be like no and it's not close
and that gives more information that
allows the system to learn and in the
same way you can say yeah that's almost
the image that I want whereas if you
give the thing a dictionary of words say
you've got your ten thousand words and
the usual way of representing this is
with a one heart two vector if you have
ten thousand words you have a vector
that's ten thousand long ten thousand
dimensions and all of the values are
zero apart from one of them which is one
so like the first word in the dictionary
if it's like a then that's represented
by a 1 and then the rest of the 10,000
to zeros and then the second word is
like a 0 and then a 1 a 10 all zeroes
and so on but there you're not giving
any of those clues if the thing is
looking for one word and it gets a
different word all you can say is yeah
that's the correct one or no that's not
the correct one something that you might
try but you shouldn't because it's a
stupid idea is rather than rather than
giving it as a one heart vector you
could just give it as a number but then
you've got this indication that like two
words that are next to each other in the
dictionary
we are similar and that's not really
true right like if you have a language
model and you're trying to predict the
next word and it's saying I love playing
with my pet blank and like the word
you're looking for is cat and the word
it gives you is car lexicographically
they're pretty similar but you don't
want to be saying to your network are
you know close that was very nearly
right because it's not very nearly right
it's a nonsense prediction but then if
it said like dog you should be able to
say no but that's close right because
that is a plausible completion for that
sentence and the reason that that makes
sense is that cat and dog are like
similar words what does it mean for a
word to be similar to another word and
so the assumption that word embeddings
use is that two words are similar if
they are often used in similar contexts
so if you look at all of the instances
of the word cat in a giant database you
know giant corpus of text and all of the
instances of the word dog they're going
to be surrounded by you know words like
pet and words like you know feed and
words like play and you know that kind
of thing
cute etcetera right and so that gives
some indication that these are these are
similar words the challenge that word
embeddings are trying to come up with is
like how do you represent words as
vectors such that two similar vectors
two similar words and possibly so that
directions have some meaning as well
because then that should allow our
networks to be able to understand better
what we're talking about in in in text
so the thing people realized was if you
have a language model that's able to get
good performance of like predicting the
next word in a sentence and you the
architecture of that model is such that
it doesn't have that many neurons in its
hidden layers it has to be compressing
that information down efficiently so
you've got the inputs do you network
let's say for the sake of simplicity
your language model is just taking a
word and trying to guess the next word
so we only have to deal with having one
word in our input but so our input is
this very tall thing right 10000 tall
and these then feed into a hidden layer
which is much smaller I mean it's more
than five but it might be like a few
hundred maybe let's say 300 and these
are sort of their connections and all of
these is connected to all of these and
it feeds in and then coming out the
other end you're back out to ten
thousand again right because your output
is it's gonna make one of these hi you
do something like softmax to turn that
into a probability distribution so you
give it a word from your dictionary it
then does something and what comes out
the other end is probability
distribution where you can just like
look at the highest value on the output
and that's what it thinks the next word
will be and the higher that value is the
more like confident it is but the point
is you're going from 10,000 to 300 and
back out to 10,000 so this 300 has to be
if this if this is doing well at its
task this 300 has to be encoding sort of
compressing information about the word
because the information is passing
through and it's it's going through this
thing that's only 300 wide so it in
order to in order to be good at this
task it has to be doing this so then
they were thinking well how do we pull
that knowledge out it's kind of like in
an egg drop competition is this where
you have to devise some method of safely
getting the egg to the floor right it's
not like the teachers actually want to
get an egg safely to the ground right
but they've chosen the task such that if
you can do well at this task you have to
have learned some things about physics
and things about engineering I'm
probably team work and yeah right right
exactly so it's there it's the friends
you make along the way so so the way
that they the way that they build this
is rather than trying to predict the
next word although that will work that
will actually give you word embeddings
but they're not that good because
they're only
immediately adjacent word you you look
sort of around the word so you you give
it a word and then you sample from the
the neighborhood of that word randomly
another word and you train the network
to predict that so the idea is that at
the end when that when this thing is
fully trained you give it any word and
it's going to give you a probability
distribution over all of the words in
your dictionary which is like how likely
are each of these words to show up
within five words of this first word or
within ten or you know something like
that if their system can get really good
at this task then the weights of this
hidden layer in the middle have to
encode something meaningful about that
input word and so if you imagine the
word cat comes in in order to do well
the probability distribution of
surrounding words is going to end up
looking pretty similar to the output
that you would want for the word dog so
it's going to have to put those two
words close together if it wants to do
well at this task and that's literally
all you do so so so if you run this on a
lot it's it's absurdly simple right but
if you run it on a large enough data set
and give it enough compute to actually
perform really well it ends up giving
you each giving you for each word a
vector that's of length however many
units you have in your hidden layer
which for which the the nearby nurse of
those vectors expresses something
meaningful about how similar the
contexts are that those words appear in
and our assumption is that words that
appear in similar contexts are similar
words and it's slightly surprising how
well that works and how much information
it's able to extract
so it ends up being a little bit similar
actually to the way that the generative
adversarial network does things where
what we're training it to produce good
images from random noise and in the
process of doing that it creates this
mapping from the latent space to images
by doing basic arithmetic like just
adding and subtracting vectors on the
latent space would actually produce
meaningful changes in the image so what
you end up with is is that same
principle but for words so if you take
for example the vector and it's required
by law that all explanations of word
embeddings use the same examples to
start with so if you take the vector for
King subtract to the vector for man and
add the vector for woman you get another
vector out and if you find the nearest
point in your word embeddings to that
vector it's the word Queen and so
there's a whole giant swath of like ways
that ways that ideas about gender are
encoded in the language which are all
kind of captured by this vector which we
won't get into but it's interesting to
explore I have it running and we can
play around with some of these vectors
and see where they end up so I have a
this running in Google collab which is
very handy I'm using word embeddings
that were found with the word Tyvek
algorithm using Google News each word is
mapped to 300 numbers let's check
whether what we've got satisfies our
first condition we want dog and cat to
be relatively close to each other and we
want cat to be like further away from
car than it is from dark right we can
just measure the distance between these
different vectors I believe you could
just do model dot distance distance
between car and cat ok is 0.78 4 and
then the distance between let's say dog
and cat 0.23 right
Dogen counter closer to each other this
a good start right and in fact we can
let's find all of the words that are
closest to capped for example okay so
the most similar word to cat is cats it
makes sense
followed by dog kitten feline beagle
puppy pup Pet felines and Chihuahua
right so so this is already useful it's
already handy that you can throw any
word at this and it will give you a list
of the words that are similar whereas
like if I put in car I get vehicle cars
SUV minivan truck right so this is
working the question of directions is
pretty interesting
so yes let's do the classic example
which is this if you take the vector for
King subtract the vector form an add the
vector for womenn what you get somewhat
predictably is Queen and if you put in
boy here you get girl if you put in
father you get mother yeah and if you
put in shirt you get blouse so this is
reflecting something about gender that's
that's in the in the dataset that it's
using this reminds me a little bit of
the unicorn thing where you know the
transformer was able to infer all sorts
or or appear to have knowledge about the
world because of language right right
but the the thing that that I like about
this that that is that that transformer
is working with 1.5 billion parameters
and here we're literally just taking
each word and giving 300 numbers you
know if I go from London and then
subtract England and then add I don't
know Japan we'd hope for Tokyo we hope
for Tokyo and we get Tokyo we got Tokyo
twice weirdly Tokyo Tokyo why is oh oh
sorry it's no we don't we get Tokyo and
toyco a typo I guess and so yeah we're
USA in New York ah okay interesting
maybe it's thinking largest city of yeah
right right like
the exact relationship here isn't clear
we haven't specified that what does it
give us for Australia
I bet it's yes Sydney Sydney Melbourne
so it's yeah it's not doing capital it's
just do largest city right but that's
cool
it's cool that we can extract the
largest city and like this is completely
unsupervised
it was just given a huge number of news
articles I suppose and it's pulled out
that there's this relationship and that
you can follow it for different things
you can take the vector from pig to oink
right okay and then like you put cow in
there that's Moo you put out in there
and you get knowing but dog in there you
get box right close enough for me yeah
yeah you put but then then it's it gets
surreal you put Santa in there oh ho ho
what does the Fox say Phoebe what so it
doesn't know basically although the
second thing is chittering two foxes
chitter I don't know gobble they go ding
a ling ling ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding
not in this data set